okay
good uh sorry that i cannot come to the
campus today but i am physically in
berkeley so uh today i'm gonna talk
about implicit regularization in deep
learning
so let me just start by briefly
reviewing the pipeline of deep learning
so usually we first need to have a data
set so for example imagenet is the one
of the most popular
and then we need to design a model and
in the context of deploying the model is
usually in the form of a deep neural
network and there are usually many many
parameters in the model and we want to
find a configuration of these parameters
such that the model can perform well on
the data population and the way to find
such parameters is to try to minimize
some loss function some training loss
function which basically measures how
well the model performs on the training
data set and in practice the loss is
usually minimized by the gradient design
algorithm or some variance of the
gradient descent algorithm and this
pipeline has achieved tremendous success
in practice
which is very mysterious from a
theoretical perspective
and one of the biggest mystery is one of
the biggest mysteries in the theory of
deep learning is the so-called
generalization mystery that is over
parametrized neural networks can
generalize well meaning that they not
only can fit the training samples but
also perform well
unseen test samples
so so
let me use a simple example to
illustrate this uh let's say this this
is our training data set with images of
cats and docs
and when we train a neural net to
classify these data sets the neural net
could learn this blue boundary for
example
but because the the model is usually
highly over parametrized it is also
capable of representing very complicated
functions uh for example this red
boundary which looks very different from
the blue one but these two solutions
perform equally well on the training
data set so they both have zero training
arrow but they may perform very
differently on new test samples because
these two are very different functions
that means even if we successfully solve
the optimization problem and get small
training arrow that doesn't imply we
will have generalization we will have
small test error because in principle we
don't know whether we found the blue
solution or the red solution
if we just look at the training training
arrow but in practice
just by minimizing the training loss
using gradient descent-like algorithms
we can somehow often find solutions that
generalize well to test samples and this
is the the mystery that's not well
understood
and what is believed to be an
explanation of this behavior is that
there's an implicit regulation effect
from the optimization algorithms we use
the main proposal is that the
optimization algorithms such as gradient
descent or stochastic gradient descent
prefers low complexity solutions so even
if the whole model space is very complex
gradient design will only find certain
low complexity solutions for some reason
and that if that's true that would imply
a good generalization performance
so i'm gonna present two uh simple deep
learning examples where we are able to
mathematically characterize the implicit
organization going on there so the first
one is for linear networks and the
second is for nonlinear networks
so let me uh go into the first example
so for for this example we will consider
this classical problem of matrix
completion so the goal of measures
completion is to recover a low rank
matrix given only a subset of its
entries
and this is a well-stated problem in
machine learning and statistics and the
typical application is in recommendation
systems so think about predicting user
ratings but given only a subset of the
ratings so today for simplicity we'll
just assume that
this ground choose matrix which i call m
is a square matrix so it's a d by d
matrix and it it has low rank
uh so uh so how do you solve this
problem the first we can easily write
down a naive training loss which looks
like this but we try to find a matrix w
which is uh our model that minimizes
this training loss over the observed
entries
and of course many optima exists for
this problem because we can just assign
any values to the unobserved entries so
there's no hope of recovering the true
matrix m using this naive approach but
that's simply because we haven't used
the assumption that the matrix should be
low rank so we may want to add some
explicit regularization
to encourage low rank and the classic
approach is to add a nuclear norm
regularization like this we recall that
nuclear norm is the sum of all the
singular values of a matrix which can be
viewed as a convex relaxation of the
rank
but what what we are considering today
is a different and a counter-intuitive
approach which i call a deep learning
approach so what we do here is to try to
find this matrix m as a product of
multiple matrices and in the language of
deep learning uh this can be viewed as a
deep linear network because it's
parameterized as a product of l matrices
w1 through wl which is a composition of
l layers of linear transformations so
here's the objective function
corresponding to this approach and so
it's a function of this l matrices w1
through wl and notice that here i'm i'm
requiring all these matrices to have to
be size d by d so we are by doing this
we are not imposing any constraint on
the rank of the matrix and actually it's
very easy to see that this problem is
exactly the same as the problem in this
naive method because we can still
express all the d by d matrices is using
the product of multiple d by d matrices
so it seems that doing this
reprimatization doesn't make much sense
and we wouldn't expect this to be useful
at all
but the but the surprise is that
empirically if we just minimize this new
objective using gradient descent with
initialization close to zero we can
we can almost always recover the ground
choose matrix and accurately
and this is surprising because we are
not explicitly asking for a low rank
solution in the objective
so the only possibility is that the
optimization algorithm we use which is
gradient descent in this case has an
implicit regulation that somehow can
help us find the low rank branches
matrix
and this implicit regulation effect we
can understand it uh by analyzing the
dynamics of the gradient descent
algorithm in this problem and an
important step in the analysis is to
derive the dynamics of the singular
values of the solution matrix which is
this equation and from from this
equation we can see that the depth the
number of layers l affects this dynamics
via this blue vector and we can
interpret it as inducing a rich get
richer phenomenon among different
singular values which encourages low
rank because different singular values
will grow at very different rates
according to this equation and we can
verify this intuition by plotting the
evolution of all the singular values
during the course of gradient descent
okay so basically for this problem we
had a very nice mental picture of how
the gradient descent algorithm prefers
low complexity solutions and the
appropriate notion of complexity here is
the rank of the solution matrix and and
we can divide the space of all the
solutions according to their rank
and our grant use matrix might be here
which is a low rank global minimum of
the loss function but there are also
many other global minima which have
higher rent and they all have zero
training loss
but so what happens uh when we run
gradient descent starting close to zero
is that it will search first search over
the rank one spaces and then the rank
two ranks three and eventually it will
settle down at a low rank minimum so it
will never reach these higher rank
spaces so it won't go to all those
non-generalizable minima and this is
done implicitly by running gradient
descent
so we can view uh this dynamic picture
uh
as indicating a more general statement
that uh maybe neural network learns
functions of increasing complexity
during training and the notion of the
complexity in this example was the rank
of the matrix
and and this general hypothesis is to
believe to be perhaps true
in some sense but in general we still
don't know what is the right way to
characterize the complexity of neural
networks and especially in non-linear
deep neural networks uh this becomes
much more challenging than linear
networks
uh so and next i'm gonna very briefly
talk about another interesting
theoretical result along the lines of
this general hypothesis and in
particular we will show that in some
natural settings a non-linear network
trained by gradient descent only learns
a linear function first before it starts
to learn anything else
and so the formal result is for a
standard two-layer neural network and by
gradient descent so the network looks
like this so it has two layers and
there's non-linearity in the hidden
layer of the network
and we also consider a hypothetical
process
which is a linear model also trained by
gradient descent so uh so it's just a
simple linear model on the input x so
the beta 1 and beta 2 here are the
parameters in this linear model
and what we prove uh is that these two
processes can be coupled and
specifically in the early time of
running gradient descent the neural
network and the linear model compute
almost the same function for input x
coming from the underlying data
distribution
so that means although the neural
network has non-linear capacity
uh if we but if when we are running
gradient descent it will implicitly bias
the neural network towards a simple
linear function at the beginning of of
training so this is also a very
interesting implicit realization effect
so here are some experiments to to
verify this result so basically these
plots are showing that uh the neural
network uh and the hypothetical linear
model basically behave the same in the
in the early time of gradient descent
which verifies uh this theorem
okay so so to to conclude uh i argued
that uh the implicit regulation effect
from the optimization algorithms is key
to understanding the generalization
behavior in modern deep learning and i
presented two case studies where we are
able to show that uh show exactly how
neural network learns functions of
increasing complexity during the course
of gradient descent and these examples
also show that uh perhaps analyzing the
dynamics of the learning procedure may
be important to understand or even just
to describe the implicit requisition
effect in deep learning
okay that's the end of my talk and uh
feel free to get in touch if you are
interested in chatting about deep
learning thanks
[Music]
um
we'll move to my no list now so i'll
just tell this in a chat
amanolis do you hear me
[Music]
yep i can hear you can you hear me yes